yeah
behind us is the open air flea market
these are gynecological instruments what
okay who buys these do people buy these
uh I'm assuming doctors do don't doctors
don't come to a flea market to buy their
gynecological instruments
is this uh Russian
see here Stalin yeah
I hate to put the onion in your bush but
what time is up see
I will waste hours
this is Vladimir Lenin it's a pizza yes
no no no extra toppings I'm not paying
for it what is this
I think yeah
oh it's a helmet worn during a war
I'm guessing he didn't survive
we're in the painting section of the
flea market and so we should keep an eye
out I think your dad said maybe a
painting yeah so let's keep an open mind
this is uh the famous part of the New
Testament where Jesus gets locked out of
his house
damn keys and guess what we found your
dad's painting
is the painting that I am buying for
your father
and I insist
it hang
in your parents home
I don't think my mom's gonna like that
painting it's not for your mom
your dad asked for painting and I think
this is going to make him very happy you
painted this yeah
yeah strobe
how much
100 100
I'll go higher oh my God I'll give you
200 American dollars
but he originally asked for a hundred
dollars and I'm saying I'm gonna give
him 250 dollars okay but I want to meet
the girl where's the girl
you sick freak
if I commission you and pay you will you
will you paint the rest
you know oh I need the rest make the
rest is for me I just want that section
[Music]
[Applause]